[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous les humains voulons tous la même
chose un lieu de vie sûre pour nous et
nos enfants
le changement climatique est bien réel
et on mesure assez mal encore les
impacts de nos actions sur
l'environnement
les impacts sont sérieux et même si on a
du mal à le protéger ou même à s'y
intégrer selon le point de vue ils
méritent aujourd'hui une réponse à plus
large échelle
je m'appelle ezzouar simoneau je suis
consultant en ressources humaines et en
responsabilité sociétale des entreprises
mais avant ça et surtout triple papa de
deux petites filles et d'un grand garçon
alors pourquoi vous parlez de ça
maintenant parce que sans rentrer dans
un futur très lointain on appréhende
déjà une triple problématique de
surpollution d'effondrement des
ressources notamment fossiles ainsi que
de changements climatiques alors à titre
d'exemple
cet été il s'est passé plein de choses
et notamment la partie française
des scientifiques du giec a finalement
fait un pronostic pour la fin du siècle
de l'ordre de + 7 degrés ça a pas l'air
de grand chose mais la différence qu'il
ya entre 4 et 7 degrés à l'échelle de la
biosphère c'est la différence qui est
entre la vie et la mort à beaucoup plus
courte échéance 2030 sera déjà le
dernier appel pour du pétrole pas cher
on est en train d'épuiser les ressources
le conventionnel s'est tarie en 2008 et
le shell oil est en train de faire de
même
si on écoute le pape de l'énergie
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle jean marc
jancovici enfin que je vous encourage
vivement à suivre il nous explique
quelque chose il nous dit même les
foyers aux revenus minimum ne pourrait
pas à l'heure actuelle être soutenables
sur le plan énergétique et ça en réalité
c'est un énorme problème parce que à qui
la faute
dans le fond
c'est au consommateur est-ce que c'est
aux fabricants est-ce que c'est au
modèle économique
on est coupable indubitablement coupable
de ne pas avoir senti qu'on faisait
fausse route
coupable de considérer uniquement la
croissance économique comme seul et
unique facteur et comme seul indicateur
dans un univers aux ressources finies
alors coupable avec des circonstances
atténuantes parce que les modèles
culturels font qu on avait du retard sur
ce niveau de conscience moi je suis né
dix ans après le rapport meadows et dans
ma télé quand j'étais petit c'était
tonnerre mécanique k2000 supercopter
plus vite plus vite si j'en reviens à
mes impact je me suis aperçu que j'avais
besoin d'y voir clair
il ya des choses qui sont des choix des
choses qui sont des contraintes alors le
plus simple est encore de créer une
petite matrix
comme vous voyez ici et sur cette
matrice d'arriver à calculer quelles
sont véritablement toutes nos émissions
et là on a déjà un niveau de surprise
très fort je me suis aperçu qu'en fait
il y avait 40 voitures de sport dans ma
maison sans que je le sache
en lieu et place d'une vilaine chaudière
à mazout ce chiffre est vrai ma
chaudière pollue 40 fois plus que ma
voiture
donc une fois qu'on a pu hiérarchiser
ces choses là on va être capables
ensuite d'y mettre un petit peu de notre
libre arbitre partie contrainte ou
liberté si je ne veux absolument pas
faire l'effort
je déplace à droite si en revanche je
suis prêt à le faire que ça ne me coûte
rien je déplace vers la gauche et se
dégage quatre zones et autant de
stratégies sur la partie verte que vous
avez on a une zone qui correspond
purement et simplement à du gâchis c'est
à dire j'ai très très peu d'efforts à
faire et les effets pour la planète sont
énormes
puis un peu de chances -moins y avait
deux tiers pratiquement de mes émissions
à ce niveau là et la stratégie qu'on va
employer
elle sera un changement quand ça nous
demande rien en revanche si vous
demandez un grand magna de la côte de
boeuf de devenir végétarien pour lundi
prochain
vous risquez d'essuyer une lourde
déception et du coup ça va nous obliger
pour ça à travailler davantage
l'amélioration continue on commence par
se dire je commence par enlever dans la
semaine un repas carnés puis
puis trois et on continue comme ça voilà
ce que je vous disais en fonction de la
contrainte ou des envies on a déjà
différentes stratégies la zone noire
beaucoup d'efforts pour peu d'effet
quand on arrive à devoir l'a traité on a
en général traiter quatre cinquièmes de
toutes ces émissions
du coup on n'est pas obligé de tout
hypothéqué voilà de façon un petit peu
plus imagée et jeu de l'oie ce que ça
donne
et sur le plan du collectif maintenant
c'est un petit peu plus difficile
une fois que j'ai fait ça j'ai une un
effet positif mais pour arriver à
demander et à offrir une véritable
dynamique il faut de l'aide
il faut se synchroniser il faut se
coordonner et dans ce cadre là j'ai
également créé du coup une plateforme
qui a un avantage certain qui est
qu'elle nous permet de boucler
absolument tout le cycle pour les
méticuleux et les insomniaques sachez
qu'il existe sur internet et que je
serais ravi d'en discuter à gauche quand
on a toujours un double tranchant au
niveau des plateformes
quand on fait du numérique on se
retrouve parfois plus vite du côté du
problème que de la solution et ça ça
tient en général au besoin qu'on a de
rendre tout très très sexy pour qu'on
reste très très longtemps
et moi j'aimerais beaucoup en réalité
qu'une enceinte connectés qui jusqu'ici
est pas très bavarde
j'aimerais qu'au lieu de m'écouter en
douce elle soit susceptible cinq minutes
tous les soirs quand je rentre après mon
travail de se livrer à une
questionnements au niveau diagnostic
c'est à dire ça m'intéresserait qu'elle
s'intéresse à qui je suis comment po
luge
pourquoi coluche
et quels sont les leviers à ma
disposition pour ne plus polluer
davantage de passer par la voie
c'est un marchepied c'est à dire que le
fait de démarrer va vraiment faire qu'au
bout d'un moment on se prend au jeu et
quand on aurait l'impression de vite
s'essouffler on s'aperçoit en finalité
que tout est absolument tous les sujets
sont des leviers potentiels
imaginez maintenant que toutes les
données soient mutualisés on va pouvoir
se retrouver avec les barreaux m
pourquoi est-ce qu'un baromètre est
important c'est parce que il nous permet
de piloter en temps réel un baromètre
finalement à l'échelle de nos éco-gestes
et notre bonne pratique exactement la
même chose qu'un google satellite en
temps réel sur ce qu'il nous faut
déployer si on sait en temps réel à
grande échelle cela où on est bon pour
générer des économies on pourra d'un
point de vue global politique d'un point
de vue même financier mettre les
incitations et mettre les moyens
nous on en a besoin c'est va remettre là
nous permettrait d'avoir des
informations de qualité en temps réel
nous permettrait d'avoir un observatoire
des pratiques commerciales
mais l'objectif est vraiment pouvoir
nous réinscrire du virtuel vers le réel
et aller nous chercher pour ça en
bâtissant quelque chose qui nous
ressemble de nous transmettre également
un goût pour passer de l'individuel au
collectif un goût pour passer de la
théorie à la pratique
et pour passer des principes aux
engagements est ce qu'on a le choix
on a le choix de militer pour le plaisir
et de se préparer au drame où on a le
choix de faire comme andré comte
sponville et de se dire mieux vaut
penser que de se lamenter
mieux vaut agir peut trembler je vous
remercie